one of the things that has helped
experts so worried about the Cova 19
pandemic is the fact that this
coronavirus is new unlike the flu or
other diseases we simply don't have any
treatments or vaccines developed for it
but today we're going to talk to one
researcher who is developing a vaccine
for this disease and is so confident
that it'll work he's going to do the
first injection on himself so if I'm
understanding correctly you're taking
the vsv virus giving it the gene that
produces the the spike protein which is
something that's unique to the Co v2
virus and that will train much like if
you injected on me it would train my
immune system to attack Kovu 2 without
actually giving me any risk of getting
the disease myself so that's that's the
correct Alex so what I'm doing is taking
the SG that entire gene the protein gene
put that into the vsv so we are making
recombinant vsv that recommend vsv when
we immunize that as a vaccine will
produce that's the spike protein and
that that protein will trainers or
educate our immune system to antibodies
that antibody will neutralize real virus
that's so that's how the vaccine works
so that's approach and we have done it
already
with both corona virus using the spy
protein genes I have total confidence
that it's going to work just as the
merck of ours was working and i'm
curious
a with at least what you anticipate with
the work that you've done so far
will this be a vaccine that you know I
might only take once or twice in my
lifetime or is it something that I might
have to get booster shots for do we know
enough to know about that yet so we will
have a tweet mitigations to get the
proper immune responses and
who in Prime and booster vaccinations
should establish very good immune
responses now how long will this immune
response or the protective period last
we don't know we have to wait and see
how well we are protected for the future
so and I know this clinical trial on it
because you're fast tracking it would we
focus on efficacy but are there any
safety concerns that you see with this
platform and in the work you've done on
other vaccines or does it seem
relatively safe for this platform
technology is relatively safe and
therefore I will volunteer for first
injection just to curiosity what is the
timeline for developing this vaccine
look like like when do you expect to you
know take that first shot and and and
start testing with people well I can
only hope for it that we are doing
almost work 24/7 but you can get this
vaccine and put it into my arm in three
months in three months Wow and and then
how long will it take them to go through
the the clinical trial process would you
expect you know best-case scenario you
know one would this be available but
this can go with the fast-track process
normally if you develop a vaccine
it has schools through the preclinical
animal tests and then safety tests and
all that before you can give it to human
but since we are in crisis and this
pandemic
I don't know how widely is going to
infect the whole world its scenario we
may be able to get the permission to
testing humans very fast
you